for this week's classic interview we're
going back to my interview with James
Lansbury James says that religious
employers should not cover birth control
this is very relevant in the context of
the Brett Kavanaugh confirmation
hearings this is very relevant in the
context of my conversation with Andrew
Seidel earlier this week about
separation of church and state
great interview that we are going to go
back to from March of 2012 with James
Lansbury let's take a look James LAN
Barre is the president of Alliance of
health care sharing ministries James
great to be with you today let's just
get right into it why should Catholic or
other religious employers have the
ability to exempt coverage for something
like contraception on a religious basis
well every American should have the
liberty to decide exactly what they want
to cover with their health insurance
policy as an employer I think that we
respective of individual religious
freedoms every American should have that
kind of liberty the employer should be
able to decide whether or not to cover
health insurance whether to include
maternity birth control any other topic
that they might want to consider to
cover in their employee plan or not at
all and so when you extend that into
then just from general Liberty into
religious liberty every American also
ought to have the freedom to be able to
exclude from their insurance policy
anything they find morally objectionable
and this is historically goes back to
the Hyde Amendment for Medicaid funding
that has occurred every single time
Congress appropriates money for Medicaid
the Hyde Amendment has been included in
that under the principle that Americans
shouldn't be forced to pay for abortion
with their taxpayer dollars okay now
you're talking about abortion I'm
talking about simply contraception sure
but the principle is still the same when
it comes to contraception the reason
that Americans shouldn't be forced to
pay for abortion is because a
significant portion of Americans find
abortion to be morally objectionable
well for only Catholics and for some
projects
paying for birth control falls on that
same moral objection and to so to force
them with their own private funds to pay
for something they find morally
objectionable is a violation that same
principle of religious liberty that's
contained in that Hyde Amendment isn't
it contradictory though because so many
who describe themselves as pro-life are
against abortion but they also want to
support policies like limiting
affordable access to contraception isn't
that simply going to cause and lead to
more pregnancies and simply as a numbers
game even more abortions which is what
they're trying to prevent they claim
well it may cause more pregnancies the
issue is whether or not access to
contraception is actually being limited
and so if we're gonna argue from a
principle that not covering it was zero
dollars in copay on an insurance policy
for employees limits access to birth
control I think that's a ludicrous
argument you know women who want access
to birth control have found access to it
over the years and not having it covered
on your insurance plan is a very small
limiting access compared to having to go
and get a doctor's prescription before
you can actually buy those birth control
pills yeah I don't think so though I
mean everything we've seen I mean
Republicans have been trying to prevent
people like MS fluke who Rush Limbaugh
eloquently called the [ __ ] the other day
from testifying about how difficult it
actually can be $1,000 a year something
which a college student may not have
access to so we have plenty of evidence
but what you're saying is there's no
evidence that not having birth control
might not increase pregnancies is that
what you said
no I said there's no evidence that
having to pay for it out of pocket
presents any greater of an obstacle to
get any birth control than having it
covered on your insurance playing it
with zero copay because as soon as you
cover that insurance under your
insurance that birth control was zero
copay all that does is move the cost
from one to a pool of money to another
pool of money and either the employer is
going to have to pay for that which is
going to read and with lower wages for
the employee or the employees gonna have
to pay for that through their insurance
premiums somewhere by that argument you
know I don't buy that argument because
we're talking look at all the suite of
things which are
covered by by health insurance you're
talking people are going to net
downwardly adjust the wages based on the
addition of birth control coverage when
we when you're talking about someone
that's not it really a good argument I
don't think I don't think anybody buys
that what whether anybody buys it or not
doesn't change that it's actually
economically true whether the wages
actually get adjusted downward or
whether they just move upward with more
slowness right doesn't change anything
the employer can still the cost of
employing an individual is still the
same whether or not they paid out all in
wages whether it's part of the insurance
package whether it's part of taxes that
are associated with that the cost of an
employee an individual is still the same
when the market is going to adjust those
wages plus benefits into a comfortable
position over time no matter what we
forced the employer to pay for sure
namely the thing that won't get up the
thing that will drive it way up is when
they have to start covering all of the
pregnancies which will result as from
not having access to birth control but
let me go into another angle here vary
things that's not true I insurance
companies have done the actuarial
studies and actually providing birth
control in the aggregate has not shown
itself to lower costs in the aggregate
at all versus just covering the
maternity care that will go along with
that yeah otherwise okay first companies
would already be covering this for free
because it would make complete sense to
them and it would maximize their profits
well if you're not do something it saves
money James it does make complete sense
it's for religious reasons that they
don't want to cover but I don't want to
get bogged down on that we'll have to
agree to disagree and I don't have this
to that study in front of me so we'll
have to save that for another time the
Bible prohibits eating shellfish in
Leviticus 11:10 if an employer wanted to
not provide coverage for an allergic
reaction resulting from eating shellfish
that's in the Bible would that be okay
would that be acceptable to cherry-pick
that and say no coverage we let them die
unless they can fork over the entire
emergency room bill
well I would say that under the
principles of American liberty that that
should be a an allowable exception in
the first place I think that the way
you're applying that is fully ludicrous
you know saying that urgency room
coverage for not eating shellfish is
completely different than issues related
to birth control and religious liberty
house romantics but how is it different
though well the difference is that for
Roman Catholics they believe that a
birth control pill is actually an
abortifacient drug they believe that
it's actually that plus the plan B
emergency contraception and is actually
wrong oh why is what wrong why do and
then so why does that make it something
they don't want to cover because their
religion tells them so right that's
correct the same way as you shouldn't be
eating shelling at stake here an actual
life at stake as opposed to merely a
cost situation that's going on along
with that emergency room visit and see
the issue here is not just what do we
force people to cover because he until
the government passed the Affordable
Care Act employers were free to design
plans that met with whatever they wanted
with their own liberty and whether
you're a religious employer are not a
religious employer having that freedom
to design a plan the as you see fit is a
part of traditional American liberty and
employees are free to either say yes I
like that plan or no I'm gonna go work
for somebody that covers everything I
want them to cover and yeah I'm just
really not seeing the difference between
the shellfish example I mean to give one
other tattoos are banned in the Bible
Leviticus 19:28 tattoos can lead to
infection should a Catholic employer be
allowed to say hey we're not covering
anything because our religion says you
shouldn't have that tattoo in the first
place that would that be okay well the
Catholic Church isn't arguing that and
so we don't really need to go down that
route I would say the same if religions
if I if a different religious employer
was to say no if you get in an accident
related to a tattoo that we don't think
you should have gotten in the first
place no one's arguing
about whether or not employers should be
allowed to ban people from being hired
because they have visible tattoos that's
not what I'm talking about interning
apples and oranges but when someone
comes to work for a religious
institution they need to understand that
they're going to be finding themselves
in some sense to the religious views of
the institution they're working for okay
well yeah I think I think we're gonna
have any way to escape that without
violating religious liberty ya know
that's uh we're gonna have to agree to
disagree it's an interesting
conversation I don't really see the
difference between the birth control the
shellfish and the tattoos I have to say
you do we'll have to we'll have to agree
to disagree James Lansbury is president
of the Alliance of healthcare sharing
ministries great to talk to you and get
your perspective today James well thanks
for having me David have a great day